let's multiply seven seven times 253 and
see what we get so just like in the last
example what I like to do is I like to
rewrite the first the largest number
first so that's 253 and then write the
smaller number below it and align the
place value the seven it only has a ones
place so I'll put the seven right over
here below the ones place in 253 and
then put the multiplication symbol right
over here so you could read this as 253
times seven which we know is the same
thing as 7 times 253 and now we are
ready to compute and there are many ways
of doing this but this would you could
call the standard way so what I do is I
start with my 7 and I multiply it times
each of the numbers up here and I carry
appropriately so first I start with 7
times 3 well 7 times 3 we know is 21 let
me write that down 7 times 3 is equal to
21 you could do this part in your head
but I just want to make it clear where
I'm getting these numbers from what I
would do in the standard method is I
would write the 1 into 21 down here but
then carry the 2 to the tens place now I
want to figure out what 7 times 5 is now
I want to figure out what 7 times 5 is
we know from our multiplication tables
that 7 times 5 is equal to 35 now we
can't just somehow put the 35 down here
we still have to deal with this 2 that
we carried so we compute 7 times 5 is 35
but then we also add that 2 so it's 35
plus 2 is 37 now we write the 7 right
over here in the tens place and carry
the 3 carry the 3 now now we need to
compute what 7 times 2 is we know that 7
times 2 is 14 from our multiplication
tables we can't just put a 14 down here
we have this 3 to add so we 7 times 2 is
14 plus 3 is 17 so now we can write the
17 down here because 2 is the last
number that we have to deal with and so
we have our answer seven times 253 is
1700 and
anyone